بناء على تطور الذي احرزناه اليوم والثقه
التي اظهرها شركائنا الاوكرانيين لكافه
انحاء العالم من حيث عزيمتهم في للفوز في
هذه المعركه الولايات المتحده سوف تقام
ملتزمه في قياده هذه الجهود وفي هذا
الصباح
ما اثلج صدري اننا كنا قد سمعنا عن الجميع
حزن جديده من المساعدات الامنيه المخصصه
للقوات الاوكرانيه قدرها اثنين فاصل
ثمانيه مليار دولار هذه الحزمه قد تكون
وهي الاكبر منا وعيالها وسوف تساعد
اوكرانيا على الوفاء بالمتطلباتها فيما
يخص الدفاع الجوي والدخيره وكذلك منظومات
دفاعيه
وهذه الرزمه سوف تساعد
على التصدي لكافه على تامين كافه
المتطلبات اوكرانيا وتحتوي على 59 دبابه
من طرازي دبابه وتسعين ناقل الجنود مدرعه
وخمسه وثلاثين
عرب مقاومه للالغام
والالاف من
انواع
الذخيره المختلفه ساعدنا ان نسمع من
الرئيس في هذا الصباح
وما قاله ودعوني ايضا ان اعرب عن امتنان
الزعماء الاخرين الذين انضم اكليلنا بما
في ذلك صديقي او نفسي
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني واللواء ماتشد نائب
الرئيس
فيه ما تقوم به القوات الاخرانيه وتواجهه
الشعب الاخراني الاجتماع اليوم يركز على
احتياجات اوكرانيا من الدفاع الجوي وايضا
سوف يكون هناك نوع من انواع التنسيق
بحيث يتم العمل على تعزيز قدراتي اوكرانيا
العملياتيه وهذا يعني ان كل خطوه من
الخطوات
التبرع بما في ذلك الصيانه الى حين
الاستمراريه الخاصه بهذه المساعده هذا
يجسد طبيعه عملنا المشترك من حيث التدريب
بسوره جماعيه او بصوره فرديه وكما تعلمون
كان رئيس ايضا قد اعلنا في الاونه الاخيره
ان ان مبادره التدريب الامريكيه الاخيره
سوف
تعتمد على تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه التي
انطلقت في المقام الاول عام 2014 بعض
الدول الاخرى قد شمرت عن سعيديها ايضا ذلك
مجموعه من الدول الاوروبيه التي قدمت
مساعدات امنيه وعسكريه وفي هذا الغضون
مازلنا مستمرين ايضا في دعم اوكرانيا
في مجالات متعدده
وهذا كله من خلال مجموعه الاتصال
هذه الجهود مجتمعه
توضحوا مدى
واهميه التعاون الذي انطلق فيما بيننا في
ابريل عملنا يظهر كيف يمكن للدول ان تحقق
في ما بينها ان عمله سوريه وتظهر وايضا
الالتزام طويل الامر في دعم اوكرانيا
في مواجهه حرب روسيا غير المبرره
وكما راينا منذ بضعه ايام
وفاروسيا لا تزال حتى اللحظه تقوم بقصف
البنى التحتيه الحساسه والحيويه في
اوكرانيا
وتستمر في قصف المدن الاوكرانيه بالمسيرات
والصواريخ لكن الشعب الاوكراني لا ما زال
مستمرا في الصمود والقوات الاوكرانيه تقوم
بالدفاع عن بلادها وعن المواطنينها
وبيد ان وحشيه روسيا تظهر بابشع صورها لا
تزالوا القوات الاوكرانيه صامده
ما يلي وسوف ابدا في مجال الدفاع الجوي
فعاده قدمت مجموعه من التبرعات من اجل
حمايه الاجواء الاوكرانيه فرنسا والمانيا
والمملكه المتحده كلهم قد تبرعوا بانظمات
بانظمه الدفاع الجوي لاوكرانيا وتشمل
بطاريه من المانيا وهذا ياتي جنبا الى جنب
مع مساهمتنا في منظومه
هولندا قيد تبرعت بمنظومه
باتريوت بينما
كندا تقدمت ايضا
بمجموعه من المنظمات الدفاعيه والذخائر
التي سوف تساعده القوات الاوكرانيه في
صموده وسوف نعمل على
الوفاء بمتطلبات اوكرانيا فيما يخص
المركبات الثقيله الاخرى تعد الولايات
المتحده من الدول الرئيس الرئيس التي قدمت
تبرعات كبيره وقد قدمت حتى اللحظه النوعين
من انواع الدبابات الهجوميه
وانهيب الدول الاخرى ان تسير على نفس
الخطوات وكذلك السويد بدورها قدمت مسامحه
كبيره
وسوف يكون هناك
مساهمه اخرى من نوع ارتشر هاو ارتشرز
وسمعنا من دول اخرى مثل الدنمارك التي سوف
تتبرع ب 19
دول اخرى عامه الاستونيا
سوف تقدم رزمه جديده
الاعلانات هي ثمره لعملنا في مجموعه
الاتصال وهذه الالتزامات تظهر العزيمه
التي لا تهز التي يتمتع بها شركائنا من
اجل مساعده اوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها
الامر لا يتعلق فقط بامن اوكرانيا بل
بامني الاتحاد الاوروبي بالامن العالمي في
ذات الوقت
الامن يتعلق الامر يتعلق بنوع العالم الذي
نود ان نعيش فيه والعالم الذي نرغب
لاطفالنا واحفادنا ان يرثوه عنا ان مجموعه
الاتصال بدورها سوف تستمر
لسني القوانين التي يجب ان تحكم العالم
للقواعد التي يجب ان تسود واحترام سياده
الدول ويمكن لي الشعوب ان تختار مسارها
بحيث تكون خاليه وبعيده عن كافه الطغاه
وفي هذه المجموعه سوف نبقى متحدين
ومستعدون للبناء على الزخم الذي حققناه
ودعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه العدوان الروسيه
والمستمرون في العمل على ضماني حقوقي
وحريتي اوكرانيا من خلال
مساعدتنا الموسم الاول ودعوني الان احيد
الكلمه الى رئيس هيئه الاركان شكرا
سعاده وزير الدفاع على قيادتكم
وقياده مجموعه الاتصال المخصصه للدفاع عن
حريه اوكرانيا اشكر جميع الوزراء وجميع
رؤساء هيئات الاركان الذين يمثلون اكثر من
40 دوله
واودوا ان اشكر ايضا
السيد الدفاع
الذي طيحت لي فرصه للاجتماع معه في بولند
في المره الماضيه
والنائبه الذي يرافقه وهمم يظهران الوجه
الحقيقي الشجاع للجيش الاوكراني والشعب
الاوكراني ان هذا الاجتماع قد اتاح لنا
فرصه لزياره بعض اماكن التدريب في بلدان
مختلفه وخاصه هنا في رمشتاين القاعده
الجويه
ومجموعه ايضا من ممثلين عن دول النيته
الذين اطحت لهم فرصه للتحدث
معنا
من خلال هذا الاجتماع الذي امتدا على مدى
اسبوع
ولعلني
اعتبروا ان حاله الوحده التي نشهدها بين
حلفاء النت وهي فريده من نوعها لم نراها
من قبلها ان مهمه هذه الفرصه هي كمجموعه
الاتصال بقياد بقيادته الوزير اوستن هي
على حالها اننا ملتزمون بدعم اوكرانيا من
اجل الدفاع عن نفسها في مواجهه العدوان
الروسي غير المبرر وغير القانوني وكما قال
الرئيس والرئيس الوزراء
الاخرين بانه فل يستغرق الامر ما يستغرقه
فسوف نعمل على جعل اوكرانيا الدوله
تتمتعه بالحريه والسياده مجموعه الاتصال
تلعب دورا اساسيا في الدفاع في مساعده
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن سياده اراضيها وهذا
يتجلى من خلال عزيمه
الحلفاء المتحدين وقد ذكر وزير الدفاع يوم
الامس
بم اعلنه الرئيس بايدن حول حزمه من
المساعدات التي تشمل فضلا عن المساعدات
السابقه
مجموعه من
التكنولوجيات الجديده التي يمكن من خلالها
اجراء مناورات وسوف تساعد
عشرات الكتائب المتنقله او بعض الكتائب
الدفاع الجوي هذه الحزمه
تظهر
عزيمتنا المشتركه من اجل مساعده اوكرانيا
للدفاع عن نفسها في مواجهه
العدوان الاوكراني العدوان الروسي ومن اجل
تحرير كافه اراضي اوكرانيا
ومن خلال هذا الاسبوع الذي انطلقنا به في
المانيا ومن خلال زياره المشتركه لمواقعه
تدريب تخصصه جنود اوكرانيا المختلفه كلها
كانت ترمي
نص جنيه
المعدات لزياده قدرات في الجيش الاوكراني
لمواجهه الهجمات الروسيه
ومن اجل الفني عمليه الهجوميه لتحرير
الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا
وسوف يستطيعون الاوكرانيين بذلك من خلال
تكتيكات
والمعدات ان
يتحلوا بحس المناوره وان يقومون بعمليات
تنسيق بين كافه الوحدات المختلفه من خلال
عمليات واسعه الدعم الذي نقشناه اليوم من
خلال مجموعه الاتصال والتدريب الذي تطرقنا
اليه
ليس سوى امتداد اللي ما قدم بدانا به في
المقام الاول في عام 2014 رغم طبيعه
الاختلاف الملموس الذي قدم في المرحله
الحاليه لاوكرانيا
فهناك دول كثيره في العالم تستخدم اعمال
عدائيه من اجل تغيير طبيعه حدود الدول
المجاوره وهذا الامر يجب ان لا يسمح به
وفي نهايه الامر الرئيس بوتن وروسيا سوف
يدركان الخطا في حساباتهم في حساباتهم
التي ارتكبها من خلال هذه الحرب التي
اطلقها
بمحض خياله ونحن بدورنا مستمرون في دعم
اوكرانيا من اجل اعاده القواعد الدوليه
وترميمها بصوره صحيحه
السؤال الاول
مرحبا وزير الدفاع
اعتقد كثيرون من
ان اليوم سوف تكون النقاشات مرتكزه حول
الاسلحه الهجوميه
لكنكم تحدثتم عن دبابات واسلحه استراتيجيه
اليوم اليس كذلك